Visualizations like this one are a core component of exploratory
data analysis. We're going to be using the R programming
language to create these types of visualizations and to explore
data throughout the course. You can read more about the R
programming language and how it was developed by clicking on
the link in the instructor notes. We'll also learn about RStudio,
which is this program. It's a graphical user interface for
programming in R. You'll learn all about RStudio in the next
lesson, and future lessons will cover visualization and statistical
techniques for data exploration. We'll start by examining one variable
at a time in a dataset. This will give us
an idea of its underlining distribution and what type of
values the variable takes on. Eventually our visualizations will
become more complex as we look at pairs of variables
and multiple variables all at once. At the end of
the course you'll have the chance to conduct your own
exploratory data analysis. I hope you're getting excited
to explore data. See you in the next lesson.